bonjour à tous nous allons peut-être
démarré puisque le programme et
consistance matin donc nous allons
accélérer le rythme de nos réunions de
travail pour être prêt tout début
juillet aujourd'hui nous nous consacrons
la matinée à notre modèle social
un des plus généreux des pays de l' ocde
qui a été fondé au lendemain de la
seconde guerre mondiale sur la
solidarité entre tous les français la
france d'aujourd'hui n'est plus celle de
1945 quand a été créée la sécurité
sociale l'espérance de vie a augmenté la
famille a évolué et les parcours
professionnels sont moins linéaire et
les nouvelles technologies bouleversent
est totalement la société principal
poste de dépenses publiques les dépenses
sociales s'élève à près de 30 4% du pib
contre 28 en allemagne ou en grande
bretagne
chacun reconnaît la complexité du
système parfois son inefficacité trop
souvent son inéquité c'est la raison
pour laquelle les républicains propose
de refonder ce modèle social pour le
rendre plus lisible plus efficace et
moins coûteux dans une logique qui nous
est chère celle des droits et des
devoirs
trois tables rondes pour faire état de
nos priorités la première animée par
arnaud robinet député maire de reims
secrétaire national aux retraites sur
les grands défis à relever pour
conforter notre protection sociale
la deuxième animé par jean pierre door
député maire de montargis dans le loiret
secrétaire nationale à la santé sur
l'adaptation nécessaire de notre système
de santé arnaud et jean pierre ont
travaillé à une loi santé alternative à
celle de marisol touraine qu'on aura le
plaisir de discuter d'examiner à
l'assemblée nationale au mois de juin à
condition que les socialistes nous
laisse en débattre et voter puisque vous
savez que la grande mode maintenant
c'est de nous empêcher de débattre et de
voter
donc on verra quel sens
sera réservé à 7,60 et enfin une
troisième table ronde animée par claude
greff qui est députée d'indre-et-loire
délégué national aux affaires sociales
qui abordera tout à la fois
écoutez bien la famille la dépendance le
handicap les pratiques addictives les
allocations la lutte contre la fraude
le tout en trois heures jusqu'à midi
puisque nous accueillerons le président
nicolas sarkozy alors un grand merci à
tous pour votre participation à tous
ceux qui ont préparé cette réunion de
travail pour votre engagement depuis des
mois et puis à chacun d'entre vous
merci pour votre esprit de synthèse
puisqu'il faut tenir dans ces trois
heures bonne matinée à tous